زميل خالد الغراب لاهلا بك خالد اااه
الرئيس المستشار الالماني ولا في الشغل
تحدث ااا ربما في هذه الكلمه المقتضبه
وركز على ان هذا القرار قرار عادل كما
تحدث ولم ندفع لاتخاذ هذا القرار هذا
مساله ركز عليها وجاء بالتعاون والتنسيق
مع الحلفاء ما الذي لافتك في هذه الكلمه
خالته حرص المستشار الالماني على التاكيد
همم على انه يعمل كل ما يمكنه
لتفادي التصعيد في هذه الحرب حديثه كلماته
عندما يتحدث عن الحرص وهمم همم
التياق من ان هذه الخطوه لن تؤدي الى
تصعيد الحرص والحذر لضمان الامن في اوروبا
هو يعلم ان هناك حرب والحرب ليست بعيده عن
حدود المانيا وبالتالي نفهم من ذلك انه
يقلق من رده الفعل الروسي ومن هنا يقول
نحن سبق
وقمنا بامداد همم اوكرانيا بالكثير من
الاسلحه لكن كل ذلك كان يتم باحترام مبدا
اساسي هو التشاور مع الحلفاء ماذا نفهم من
كلمه التشاور مع الحلفاء ان الموقف الذي
يتخذ ليس موقف المانيا وحده وانما موقف
تحالف تحالف يعني حلف الاطلسي وبالتالي
عندما تكون هناك رده فعل لانه وصول دبابات
غربيه وهي من احدث الدبابات في العالم ان
كنت تحدثت عن دبابات الالمانيه او
الدبابات الامريكيه التي ستصل ربما لاحقا
همم هذه همم تزعج روسيا كثيره لم نعد
نتحدث عن اسلحه دفاعيه نحن نتحدث عن اسلحه
اكثر الاسلحه تقدما في العالم وتستخدم في
الهجوم وبالتالي الروسي يعلمون ان الايام
المقبله سيكون هناك مواجهات صعبه على
الجبهه وهذا سيغضب روسيا وعندما تغضب
روسيا يكون هناك رد فعل لمن ستوجه رده
الفعل ان قامت المانيا وحده بارسال
الدبابات سيكون سهل ان تكون رده فعل
باتجاه المانيا لكن عندما تكون هناك
دبابات المانيه دبابات بريطانيه والاهم
دبابات امريكيه ستفكر روسيا الف مره قبل
ان تقوم بردت فعل لانه في هذه الحاله هي
تبدا حرب هي بشكل غير مباشر مع حلف الاطلس
يعني
ممكن تفتح الابواب الى مواجهه صريحه
ومباشره مع حلف الاطلسي وبالتالي ردت
الفعل سيكون هناك همم
تفكير اكثر ربما من جانب الروسي وعدم حدوث
خطوره المواجهه همم لن تكون هناك مجازه او
المجازه فاقل ان اردتي بان تتعرض المانيا
لان تويزج بها في هذه الحرب لانها تعلم ان
هذا السلاح هو السلاح هجوم اكثر مركز عليه
المستشار الماني هي هذه الفكره همم يطمئن
الناس ان هذا القرار بالتشاور مع الحلفاء
وان انا لستنا واحده لنا لاننا نعي ان
الحرب على ابواب منها وبالتالي لن ناخذ
مخاطره لكن مستمرين في دعم اوكرانيا اا مع
احترام الا يكون هناك تصعيد كبير يعلم انه
سيكون هناك تصريف لكن يحاول ان يكون هل
يكون هناك صيد كبير وهو يتحدث عن دبابات
مع الصيانه مع الذخائر وطبعا والسماح
للشركاء الاخرين المملكه العديد من الدول
الاوروبيه التي تملك هذا نوع الدبابات ولا
تستطيع ان تمنعها او تقدمها الى اوكرانيا
بدون موافقه المانيا والمانيا اليوم
موافقه فقط طيب خالد هناك هذا الحارس
الالماني والتنسيق مع الحلفاء لكن ايضا من
الجانب الاخر هناك هذا التحذير الروسي
بحصول تصعيد اذا ما تم ربما تسليم هذه
الدبابات والامر سيتم ما الذي يمكن ان
تغيره هكذا قرارات على الارض
وصول دبابات المانيه بهذا الشكل ووصول
دبابات امريكيه لاحقا يمكن ان تغير
المعادله ان هذه الدبابات هي الدبابات
قطار رئيسيه وكما قلنا هي احدث الدبابات
تكون الحدث عن اليوبار الالمانيه او رمز
الامريكيه لكن العسكريين يضعون بعض الشروط
حتى تكون هذه الدبابات فعلا فعاله على
الارض اولا العدد لابد ان تكون كافيه من
ناحيه العدد حتى تكون تمثل القوه هجوميه
بقوه نيران كافيه لاحداث اختراق ان اردتي
في اجابات العدو وهمم الان ما الذي سمعناه
عن ايصال الدبابات يتوقع خلال ساعات ان
يعلم الامريكيون عن الارسال دبابات
العدد قد لا يتعدد حسب المصادر الامريكيه
نحو 30 دبابه بعد ان يتم نزع تكنولوجيا
خاصه بها هذه الذي تحدثت عنه مصادر
الامريكيه همم بالنسبه للدبابه الالمانيه
هي اكثر فاعليه كثيرا من الدبابه
امريكيه في هذه الظروف ليست بالضروره فقط
من ناحيه الكفاءه همم لكن ايضا ل- لظروف
خاصه بها بمعنى الدبابه الالمانيه موجوده
جغرافيا في اوروبا هي متوفره بسرعه اكبر
ومتوفره بكميات اكبر لان هناك الدول
الاوروبيه التي همم لديها نوع من الدبابات
استعدوا حتى الان بتقديم نحو مئه دبابه من
نوع اليوبار لاوكرانيا
لعدد كبير لكن ليس كافيا في مثل هذه الحرب
لكن قد تكون هي البدايه البريطانيون
يتحدثون عن اثنا عشر اهداف فقط الاعداد
حتى الان ليست بالعدد الكافي يبقى الان
الشرط الثاني ان تصل هذه الدبابات بما
تحمله من التكنولوجيا المعروفه عنها ومتى
جعلها من افضل الدبابات كما قلنا الجانب
الامريكي سينزع عنها جزء من هذه
التكنولوجيا لا نعلم بالنسبه للجانب
الالماني بالضبط همم عنصر ثالث هو تدريب
القوات الاوكرانيه حتى تستطيع اظهار
القدرات هذه الدبابه وهذا همم سيحتاج بعض
الوقت
الالمان يتحدثون عن ايصال هذه الدبابات
بعد ثلاثه او اربعه اشهر يعني ربما في
نهايه الربيع بعض التاخير لكن في هذا
الوقت يمكن ان يتم التدريب لكن هذا شرط
مهم لانه دبابه بدون ان يستطيع احد يجيد
استخدامات الدبابه لا معنى حقيقه له وهناك
شرط اخر تقني على الارض هو توفير نوع من
الحمايه لهذه الدبابه طبعا ان يتمكن اولا
من ايصالها بالسلام بدون ان تضرب وبعد ذلك
توفير نوع من الحمايه على الارض لو دبابات
على الارض بدون حمايه في السماء
مع ايجاد التوفير الدعم الكامل لها لكن
تبقى هذه الدبابه من اكثر الدبابات في
العالم تتمتع بقدره على ضرب اهداف حتى ما
بين اربعه على خمسه كيلو متر تقريبا من
اكثر الدبابات دقه في اصابه الاهداف
بالاضافه الى انها همم سريعه الحركه 70 كم
اا في الساعه ومحصنه بشكل جيد ولها همم
مستعده للحرب الالكترونيه وحتى الحرب
الكيماويه ال- ال- ال-
الاسلحه غير التقليديه يعني مجهزه بشكل
جيد جدا
ومعروف عنها سهوله الصيانه
والتدريب عليها ربما اسهل من الدبابات
الامريكيه وهي اكثر تعقيده طيب خالد ما
الذي او هل يمكن ربما ان نتوقع قرارا
فرنسيه مماثلا ما قاله الرئيس الفرنسي منه
لا نستبع له اي شيء من الممكن لان الرئيس
الفرنسي تحدث مع وزير الدفاع بالاساس حول
هذه النقطه يعني الفكره مطروحه وتبحث
لكارثه الفرنسي بوضع بعض شروط ان يتم هذا
القرار بشكل جماعي وهذا يبدو ان هذا الشرط
كان شرط الماني وتوفر الان تم احترامه
الامريكيون سيرسلون الدبابات والالمان
واضح ان القرار الجامعي اصبح موجود هذا مو
هذا الشرط توفر همم الشرط
ثاني همم هو همم قلت تعتبر هذه الخطوه
تصعيديه لو كانت فرنسا واحده كان من
الممكن ان تعتبر تصاليا لكن عندما تكون
فرنسا بعد ان يرسل الاخرون دباباتهم ستكون
يعني ممكن ان تكون صعيديه ان اردتي سيكون
هناك تصعيد سيكون هناك رجل روسي لكن ليس
بنفس الخطوره ان ترس الدوله واحده وشرط
اخر للرئيس الفرنسي همم ان همم يتم التاكد
من قدره الجنود الاوكرانيين على استخدام
هذا السلاح بالطريقه الامثل هذا من الصعب
الحكم عليه الان لكن هذا شرط يعني ممكن
استخدامه كما تريد الاراده السياسيه
لايقاف ارسال الدبابات او لارسال الدبابات
بشكل اسرع يعني لكن الشرط الاخير وهذا في
غايه الاهميه الا يؤثر ذلك على قدرات
الدفاع الفرنسيه وهذا يوحي بان حتى وان
قررت فرنسا ارسال دبابات لن يكون بالعدد
الكبير جزيلا شكرا لك يا خالد على هذه
القراءه التحلي شكرا